First, let's look at how we're going to use the decode method. It's going to
return a string with the decoded message. And it doesn't need any arguments.
So, in the decoder tester, we want to print out the result of decoder.decode.
The decoder was made with the coded messages string already in it. So we don't
need to pass that string in again. Now, back to the decoder itself. We need to
write a for loop that reads every 10th letter, starting with the 0th one. Since
we're reading a string, we want to go as long as the index is less than the
length of the string. EncodedMessage is the string that we're reading. And
instead of incrementing by one at a time I'm going to increment i by 10 every
time, so that we only see every tenth letter. Inside the loop, the part that I
want to repeat is reading the ith letter, and adding it to decoded message. So
decoded message will be itself Plus, encodedMessage.substring from i to i plus
1. Remember, this is how we got one letter out of a longer string. Let's see if
this works. Looks like there are more secret messages in here. If you're
curious what they are, I guess you'll have to try starting at different
indices. Let me talk for a moment about a couple of bugs that you might have
encountered. If you accidentally wrote less than or equals to, right here like
this. You might encounter a string out of bounds exception. When you try to
access too high of an index in encodedMessage. A string index out of bounds
exception is a runtime error. That particular runtime error is nice, because it
stops the program and tells you, you tried to access a value that doesn't
exist. Which is much better than silently messing up your program's result. You
could correctly, though, a little clumsily write the condition as, i is less
than or equal to encodedMessage.length(), minus 1. That would work, but I don't
think it's as clean. When you iterate over a string, it's best, to go, as long,
as i, is less than, the length.